sportif réjean tremblay qui est en
direct avec nous de ce très bon soir
au mois de mai dernier en avait fait un
reportage là dessus avait puis vous en
parlait dans une chronique aujourd'hui
il n'y avait pas aux québécois dans
l'alignement du canadien ça créé tout un
tollé je vous montre un graphique que je
poserai les voir mais les gens vont le
voir le nombre de québécois ou dans le
club canadien n'a pas arrêté de baisser
depuis des années le 21 pour cent
quatre-vingt-onze s'est rendu quatre
pour ça en 2020 il ya cinq joueurs
actuellement dans l'aliment bref les
gens trabi le premier ministre dit il
faut qu'il ya plus de québécois ce que
ce comité là va changer des choses selon
la vraie bonne nouvelle patrie c'est
gros face
cette conversation parce que monsieur
legault à cause des sondages cause de sa
personnalité
un bon flair
des gens au québec puis je pense qu'il a
très bien senti qu'il y avait une espèce
de mécontentement pommes des primes mais
il a hockey est le sport national c'est
le sport aussi qu'ils communiquent le
mieux avec un l'ensemble du québec on a
dû pendant les séries éliminatoires l'an
dernier puis le simple fait que
quelqu'un comme d'aucuns premier
ministre du québec réunissent des gens
et la qualité des gens au moins le guen
espèce de réveil matin qu sommes et ça
je trouve que c'est un sens est
important et la réaction des médias les
réactions des et des bébés
dans les communications mais pour juste
de sport n'importe quoi
que ce soit un élément de la société qui
est important dans ok bah oui mais on a
d'ailleurs on en parle ce soir à
l'endroit où on fait nos grandes aussi à
tous les soirs donc cei a réussi à faire
parler de ça voudrait dire beaucoup de
monde sur le comité on lui donne
quelques mois mais là on a brasse large
l'équipement coûte cher aux parents le
manque de deux jeunes d'aller dans les
équipes le lien entre l'école les élus
le fait qu'il n'y a pas assez de fait on
a brasse très large champ très large et
je pense qu'il faut bien comprendre et
ça va être un espèce de
remue-méninges de haut niveau moi ce que
j'espère qu'ils vont avant le budget
d'envoyer quelqu'un de vraiment
d'octobre comme danièle sauvageau par
exemple en suède et en finlande
la population de la dette intérieure et
celle du québec oh là là là leur
progression était fils durant au niveau
du hockey amateur donc c'est stein au
québec et les messins de l'argent je
pense que le modèle du [ __ ] voilà nos
semences et parfois dangereux mais en
plus je pense est incompétent il va
falloir trouver une autre façon mais
aussi trouver une autre façon de
financer et brillant ou tard et des
professionnels pour diriger coach epide
qui a ramené le plaisir dans les allées
nos examens
terminés ça ne parlait de trois fois en
10 ans à plus de bons salaires départ
qui deviennent fous il ya une pression
les arènes sont un lieu presque malsain
maintenant il faut ramener le goût de
jouer de mettre ses bâtons milieu de la
glace puis d'un jouet waton c'est pour
jamais oublier une chose la langue
française est extrêmement bien fait on
joue au hockey on travaille pour 11 ou
mots on a l'impression parfois que les
jeunes qui est déjà arrivé à 8,9 un atom
ou même rugby kiwi que les jeunes 16
s'amuser avec une pression qui a pas de
bon sens puis un facteur que j'ai trouvé
que monsieur legault c'est bien beau
râler un flat il keynésien dans le sens
du poil l effet sa conférence de presse
dans le centre bell p je pense que le
che legault aurait pu souligner il le
dit de façon très discrète dont on
pourrait compter également sur le
canadien de montréal parce que c'est
quand même c'est l'institution qui
représente le hockey les jeunes arrêts
les jeunes voulaient jouer pour
légaliser les jeunes l'espoir un jour
jouer avec le canadien quelqu'un comme
serge savard et avant lui sam pollock il
avait une règle alors on n'est pas
supposé échapper un seul jeune
francophone au québec chez l'homme ou de
quelqu'un à un moindre mal de talent il
faut qu'ils jouent pour le caresser
bientôt légal on prend ce canadien
depuis 20 ans sawyer j'ai laissé six
succès semble leur faire changer non
nous mouiller abominable mais en plus il
exclut pratiquement complètement touché
braga fans c'est devenu pratiquement des
trois dauphins mais est ce que c'est que
ça va changer est-ce qu'il ya quelque
chose il ya une épiphanie la chaîne
canadien
je pensais oui ça va changer parce que
mon année ça devienne que si on cache
aussi premièrement et deuxièmement la
pression c'est les personnes qui vont
travailler dans le comité qui vont
utiliser qui vont se pencher
c'est impossible que un des 14 15
personnes des esport om et si on avait
le canadien pour tirer qui lui servirait
de locomotives comme il l'a fait pendant
90 est peut-être que notre travail
serait plutôt celle aussi mais j'en
tremble et un plaisir de vous avons
parlé saluer la prochaine on va en
suisse les travaux de ce comité qui va
aller vite en princesse mois d'avril
devant être fini onze années au québec
quand vous revenez au québec ça va être
fini
ces sortes